[Música]
salud en directo américa de france a 24
y conmigo ya está en el estudio mar
romero sala mar para hablar de un tema
bastante interesante y pues yo no sé si
va a destruir este mito y mi emoción con
lo que vamos a hablar la pastilla que ha
comenzado a comercializarse en reino
unidos que promete prevenir lo que
muchos han pedido se hace muchísimo
tiempo la resaca buenos días raúl
efectivamente una pastilla que promete
prevenir la resaca al ego que creo que
nos puede aludir a los dos en este caso
y si tengo malas noticias para ti la
verdad la verdad es que bueno vamos a
seguir el estudio digamos que tenemos
que ser muy prudentes vamos a dar de
hecho unas líneas sobre cómo podemos
mirar los estudios para saber pues si
nosotros podemos leer o no y en este
caso como mínimo recomendar la prudencia
que ya sabes a qué nos gusta vamos a
hablar de qué es lo que propone
empezando esta pastilla d se llama
merkel es de una empresa sueca se está
comercializando en reino unido- y
básicamente lo que hace es reducir el
nivel del alcohol en la sangre es una
pastilla que básicamente es un propio es
decir que contiene dos bacterias que
llegan al intestino y ayudan a hacer
todo este proceso de metabolización del
alcohol antes de que el alcohol llegue a
la sangre lo que significa pues hacer
todo el proceso de que el alcohol se
convierta en acetaldehído que es la
sustancia que es más nociva para nuestro
cuerpo que luego se convierta en acetato
y por último pues se excreta se elimine
en forma de agua y dióxido de carbono
muy importante recordar que de hecho si
llega así lo que previene es que el
alcohol llegue a la sangre eso también
significa que previene la borrachera es
lo que puedes tomar más pero el nivel de
euforia que puede provocar el alcohol
será menos y lo que dicen también son
dos pastillas que se toman entre 12 y
una hora antes de empezar a beber pero
como te decía vamos a poner los puntos
sobre las íes y observar bien este
estudio en el que se basa la
comercialización de esta pastilla
primero de todo se basa en 24 individuos
son 24 individuos todos jóvenes todos
sanos y en un rango de peso medio
entonces pues sabemos que todas estas
cosas influyen en la ingesta del alcohol
en cómo se procesa después estuvieron
una semana tomando estas pastillas antes
posición al alcohol como vemos que dice
aquí el estudio y además después de toda
esta semana lo que hicieron fue tomar un
vaso moderado de alcohol the spirits
decía es decir de alcohol de alta
graduación entonces desde mi perspectiva
aquí deja muchas preguntas primero
porque de estos 24 sólo sirvieron 14
individuos porque todos tenían los otros
10 tenían un nivel de alcohol demasiado
bajo en la sangre como para ser
significativo después pues qué pasa con
gente de otras edades que pasa con gente
de otros pesos personas que tengan
enfermedades preexistentes no como
influye en este sentido y además pues
difícilmente recrea las situaciones
reales en las que uno quisiera tomar
esta pastilla porque una semana
tomándose una pastilla para luego
tomarse un vasito de alcohol no es lo
mismo pues que estar tomando las 12
horas antes y luego ingerir muchísimo
alcohol eso no quiere decir que sea malo
que tenga malos efectos porque bueno no
es mala idea ayudar la flora intestinal
pero además digamos lejos de la paz
ideal que sería emborracharse o pues
obviamente estar digamos alegre o una
fiesta ya tomar tele cuando vayas a
dormir y al día siguiente amanecer como
si nada pero creo que le estás pidiendo
a la teología más básica
entonces si mejor una pastilla cómo
podemos prevenir la resaca y pues por
supuesto yo sé que usted va a decir pues
no tomando así es más me has visto las
intenciones básicamente es no bebiendo
bebiendo con moderación en cualquier
caso pero es verdad que si repasamos el
proceso de qué es la resaca podemos ver
los lugares en los que podemos ayudar al
cuerpo digamos a sobreponerse mejor para
empezar qué pasa cuando tenemos esta
resaca es nuestro cuerpo combatiendo
pues los efectos y haciendo todo el
proceso de eliminar y descomponer el
alcohol lo más rápidamente posible
primero es deshidratación por lo tanto
pues beber agua regularmente a la vez
que estás tomando alcohol es una forma
de ayudar al cuerpo a no quedar tan
deshidratado después segundo respuesta
inmune del cuerpo se inflama eso también
haya llevado algunas personas a
recomendar por ejemplo paracetamol oa
otros antiinflamatorios pero eso no es
buena idea porque eso también lo procesa
el hígado que ya ha tenido suficiente
con la cantidad de alcohol que nos hace
tener resaca no luego también la
irritación del estómago por eso podemos
estar revueltos recordar que la pastilla
influyó sobre el intestino y no el
estómago entonces la poco ayudaría en
este ayuda a haber comido mientras
estamos tomando y también tener una
dieta sana y por último el alcohol hace
que se agregamos más insulina eso puede
llevar a una caída del azúcar también
cuando tomamos peligroso para personas
con diabetes sobre todo bueno más
dejamos a un lado esta pastilla que no
está nada milagrosa y está lejos que es
de lo que muchos querían para pasar a
hablar de un tema pues obviamente de
salud que nos concierne a todos la
vieron al mono porque sudáfrica ha
detectado su tercer caso pero ahora es
importado y raúl esto tampoco lo
queremos igual que la pastilla a pesar
de que la viruela del mono es endémica
en algunos países de áfrica no lo es en
sudáfrica que ha registrado ya tres
casos pero este último se trata de un
caso de un turista suizo que ha llegado
al país contagiado y porque nos
centramos en este caso que sería
insignificante en el panorama global
primero porque es un caso importado de
europa asia áfrica algo que es inusual
en este tipo de enfermedad y segundo
también para hacer memoria recordemos
cuando varios países cerraron las
puertas a sudáfrica cuando los detalles
detectó la variante de omicron es
pertinente preguntarnos si que
pensaríamos lo que opinaría mos y
sudáfrica hiciera lo mismo para evitar
los casos importados de europa de
viruela del mono más rápidamente porque
está sucediendo algo así pues no es raro
cuando repasamos muy rápidamente las
cifras de viruela del mono en todo el
mundo vemos que en continente africano
desde 2022 tiene alrededor de 1.700
casos aproximadamente países sobre todo
donde son endémicos pero en cambio
europa desde la primavera desde la
primavera del hemisferio norte cuando
empezó el brote ella cuenta casi 6000
casos por lo tanto europa ha superado
con creces los casos de los países
endémicos en este brote no es extraño
que empiece a exportar si empiece a
pasar esta dinámica inversa a la que
estamos acostumbrados pues mar como
siempre muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud y pues no me voy
muy contento con eso de la pastilla
active resaca de mejores noticias es
bueno esperemos más muchísimas gracias
pasamos a saludar en nuestro segundo
invitado al día